so you're a plastic company you teamed
up with oil companies to create a
miracle product that can do pretty much
anything it's cheap durable easily
accessible and easy to mass produce what
more could you ask for i know i feel
like i'm dreaming and by the 1980s
you're in your prime the only problem is
plastics can't be destroyed they just
keep piling up and up and up now this is
actually not a problem for you the more
plastic that piles up means the more
plastic you're selling but the real
problem is the general public
see the masses crave to feel that
they're good people that they're the
righteous ones the moral ones fighting
against evil
[Music]
and polluting the planet with plastic
trash that takes upwards of a half a
millennia to decompose makes you an easy
target for the plebs in their eyes
you're the evil scapegoats so the
general public starts protesting the
plastics industry now this is bad
because you know the success of anything
political movements educational
movements businesses entire industries
including the plastics industry rely on
the approval of the public if the public
turns on you you're done so you need to
come up with a solution something that
would change the public's perception of
plastic something that will allow them
to keep consuming plastic without
feeling guilty about themselves from
destroying the planet the only problem
is most plastic is literally not
recyclable it's not just that you can't
recycle plastic is that the process to
do so is so expensive and labor
intensive that making new plastic will
always be cheaper so you settle on the
next best thing this is the recycling
symbol created in 1970
and this is the resin identification
code a symbol created by the plastics
industry in 1988 a symbol that's on
almost every piece of plastic you buy
today now if you're saying to yourself
that symbol looks shockingly similar to
the official recycling symbol you'd be
correct because that was by design a
designed to intentionally deceive the
general public into believing the
plastic you buy is recyclable yes
recycling is a literal lie concocted by
the plastics industry to sell you more
plastic and this is how it was pulled
off
how much plastic could the world
possibly use
oh that's not so much
so
[Music]
i have no idea
you can even recycle your bicycle cause
all metals and plastics are recyclable
so reduce reuse recycling reduce
reusability most of what makes
people feel good about recycling is
based on misinformation the biggest
plastic manufacturer today is the dow
chemical company the dow chemical
company has over 19 million dollars in
debts that's a lot of debt we don't know
the interest rate on that debt but what
we do know is that drowning in credit
card debt and other high interest debt
to the point where you can only afford
to pay off the interest every month is a
surefire way of staying in poverty while
your lender gets rich and if you're
drowning in a lot of high interest debt
like the average american wouldn't it be
nice if you could take out a loan at a
much lower interest rate use that loan
to pay off your high interest debt so
you're left with only one single loan
that requires only one fixed monthly
payment with a clear payoff date so you
can escape this vicious cycle once and
for all well you're in luck because
that's where upstart comes in today's
video sponsor upstart is a fast easy way
to get a personal loan online to help
you pay off your high interest debt
whether you need to pay off credit cards
consolidate a bunch of high interest
debt or you just need help finding
personal expenses like medical bills
upstart can help you by giving you a
loan that requires only one fixed
monthly payment with a clear payoff
dates and the great thing is instead of
just looking at your credit score
upstart takes in other factors like your
income current employment and credit
history to help you get a smarter rate
for your loan upstart offers loans of
one thousand to fifty thousand dollars
and you can check your rate in minutes
without impacting your credit score once
you're approved you could receive your
funds in as little as one business day
find out how upstart can lower your
monthly payments today when you go to
upstart.com jaketran that's upstart.com
jake tran use my link in the description
below to let them know i sent you
upstart.com jaketran
[Music]
plastic
plastic
plastic
what are plastics
[Music]
are they
vegetable
or mineral
plastic production started in the early
1900s it was marketed as a material of a
thousand uses and it was making money
and gaining popularity slowly but it was
nowhere near its real earning potential
then world war ii hit and since economic
power was just as important as military
power wars aren't free after all the
government started prioritizing the
production of this new material that
wasn't just very useful but also very
profitable you see the military had to
get money from somewhere to keep
fighting the war and plastic was an
industry with a lot of potential just
waiting to be exploited so during world
war ii alone plastic production in the
us increased by 300 percent plastic took
the place of steel in cars and warplanes
it replaced paper and glass packaging
and even wood furniture plastics will
play as large a role in peace as they do
in war
here is a plane containing hundreds of
plastic parts
here another bonded by plastics
[Music]
this paratrooper floating down to
welcome mother earth is depending on
plastics to get in there safely
and since plastic is made from oil and
natural gas products plastic companies
suddenly emerged from the oil giants
like exxon mobil chevron and dupont and
with the backing of the fossil fuel
industry there was nowhere to go but up
it's kind of hard to illustrate just how
much of a game changer plastic was for
companies imagine spending all these man
hours machining these expensive
materials like metal wood and glass for
years and years and years and then comes
along this wonder material that was not
only orders amounted to cheaper but
could be molded into any shape and was
durable everyone was using it for pretty
much everything from chairs to cheap
jewelry to car parts but because it was
so durable and useful these plebs
started hanging onto their plastic
products they weren't throwing them away
after one single use this was a problem
for you if people reuse your plastic
indefinitely you can't make them a
repeat buyer which is where all the real
money is at so the plastic industry
launched a massive campaign millions of
dollars worth of ads encouraging people
not to be such unsophisticated peasants
reusing dirty plastic ew just throw it
away after one use what's the harm it's
so cheap to replace and it started to
work but then came the hippies
you see not everyone saw the beauty in
plastic as you did and when they started
noticing your ads telling everyone to
just chuck out their plastic and buy new
ones the plastic industry became the
prime target for destroying the
environment which led to america's first
ever earth day holiday in 1970 to
protest the use of plastic and other
pollutants one in 10 americans took
parts
now obviously this number of people
going up against your industry is not
good if everyone found out the extent of
just how bad plastics were for the
environments how they can't be destroyed
and how it kills animals you would be
out of business so you concocted a
genius plan instead of fighting the
hippies you would join them playing both
sides i'm playing both sides so that i
always come out on top
so you the other plastic companies and
the fossil fuel companies create a front
organization called keep america
beautiful a very wholesome inconspicuous
name and to kick things off you create
the crying indian ad
people start pollution
people can stop it
it's literally called the crying indian
i did not make that up hilariously the
crying indian was actually an italian
actor named iron eyes cody and
apparently impersonating native
americans was a specialty this ad played
on tvs all over america and for a hot
minute it seemed like earth day protests
were really making a difference here
were the actual plastic companies
telling people to stop littering and to
be more conscious of the environment so
the indian doesn't cry sure you could
have spent the money finding ways to
make plastic more reusable but why do
that when you can just placate the
masses by making it look like you're
trying to change and it worked people
started throwing their trash away and it
even helps out the very first few
recycling plants and those few recycling
plants gave way to the best idea yet
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
by 1970 plastic products that were
recyclable like milk jugs and soda
bottles had the official recycling
symbol stamped on them that is good news
clubs don't have to feel guilty anymore
about buying plastic milk and soda
bottles the bad news is that milk and
soda bottles make up just a tiny
percentage of all the plastic out there
with most of it not being recyclable but
there is still hope the public mind has
now associated this symbol with being
good for the planet so all you have to
do is latch onto that association so you
come up with your own version of the
recycling symbol you make the arrows a
little bit thinner you slap a number in
the center of it and then you lobby to
slap this symbol onto every plastic
product in existence
here's the official recycling symbol and
here is the resin identification marker
or resin identification code concocted
by the plastic industry
there are seven different resin
identification codes yet realistically
only two out of the seven types of
plastics can be recycled but it worked
consumers didn't know what these big
numbers meant all they saw was what
looked like a recycling symbol so they
just assumed that all plastic products
with this symbol were recyclable buying
plastic no longer meant that they were
destroying the planet so they kept on
consuming when in reality you knew the
truth that plastic recycling would never
work that it would always be too
expensive that plastic degrades every
time it was recycled so it could only
really be reused two or three times but
that didn't matter anymore because the
public's guilt was satisfied if the
public thinks the recycling is working
then they're not going to be as
concerned about the environment
and although these codes should have
made the life of recyclers easier in
theory because they can now easily
separate what is recyclable from what
isn't it had the opposite effect it made
recycling almost impossible now because
people were throwing way more junk into
the recycle bin
[Music]
in the u.s we're recycling less than 50
percent of our bottles and cans
join pepsico in the recycling of every
last bottle and can
[Music]
and the advertising campaigns didn't end
there hundreds of ads hundreds of
campaigns all encouraging people to
recycle their plastic so they could
protect the planets one plastic lobbyist
famously said what we need to do is
advertise our way out of this
the bottle may look empty yet it's
anything but trash says one ad from 1990
showing a plastic bottle bouncing out of
a garbage truck it's full of potential
we've pioneered the country's largest
most comprehensive plastic recycling
program to help plastic fill valuable
uses and
[Music]
for your rules
i'm reusing this plastic jug and making
it into a funnel and a tool holder jars
for nuts both screws nail reuse it for
the future it's worth it these ads were
made to look like they came from
environmentalists when in reality it
really came from the fossil fuel
companies behind all this plastic in the
first place
[Music]
whenever the public became outraged you
would fund more recycling initiatives
and when the public died down that
funding was pulled
with all this advertising came the
introduction of single-use plastics like
straw shopping bags bottled water a
material designed to last forever was
being thrown away after one use but
don't worry because you can recycle them
building up the industry's revenue to an
insane 1.2 trillion dollars a year
cigarette companies and the diamond
cartel are often credited as some of the
greatest marketers of all time because
of the feats they pulled off but their
practices eventually became somewhat
well known to the public but the plastic
industry today hardly anyone even knows
about the ruse that was pulled off
some recycling makes sense reusing
aluminum saves lots of energy
but just about everything else
is a scam
[Music]
we all know the good that recycling does
for darwin and its environment but a few
simple mistakes can mean the difference
between recycling right and wasting our
recycling efforts
putting plastic bags in the yellow bins
for example can send tons of good
recycling to landfill so don't let our
efforts go to waste
learn to recycle for good
[Music]
today although more and more of the
types of plastic can be recycled it
either costs way more money compared to
just making more plastic or the act of
recycling itself is even worse for the
environment paper recycling involves
bleaching and de-inking things that can
pollute the environment even more
transporting materials to recycling
plants out of states can cause even more
pollution than the recycling would make
up for all recycling isn't necessarily
good and isn't necessarily
environmentally benign well i live in
bozeman montana and in order to recycle
glass bottles we ship them down to
golden colorado and in places like la
using 400 more garbage trucks to collect
recyclable waste most of it won't be
recycled in the first place just ask the
air pollution and more taxes
after los angeles mandated recycling
they discovered they needed another 400
garbage trucks to pick up the new
container today less than 10 of all
plastic is recycled but the impressive
part is that no one is the wiser
so where does the rest of that 90 go
[Music]
when you look at plastic you know how it
helps things stay fresh and safe and
light and unbreakable and strong and
easy to carry but take another look
plastic also saves energy because it
helps make cars lighter to save gas and
plastic insulation helps save energy at
home even these strong plastic bags help
save energy because they take less
energy to make than other grocery bags
to learn more call this number for a
free booklet and take another look at
plastic
[Applause]
[Music]
most of the 300 million tons of plastic
waste produced each year that isn't
recycled ends up in landfills but not
all of it ends up there around 10
million tons ends up in the ocean each
year as well that's the equivalent of
one garbage truck full of plastic being
dumped into the ocean every single
minute according to some estimates this
could be accidental due to heavy rain
and wind moving trash into the ocean or
it could be from illegal dumping with
most of it coming from asian countries
we sell our trash to and since plastic
isn't biodegradable most of it slowly
breaks into smaller and smaller pieces
over time these tiny pieces of plastic
are called microplastics and they either
form a sludge layer in the middle of the
ocean or end up being eaten by fish and
no matter if you're a raging
environmentalist sjw or a hardcore
conservative this creates a problem for
you not only does it kill marine life
like dolphins and whales we all know
about that but that same plastic ends up
seeping its way into practically
everything we eat it's in the delicious
sushi i'm addicted to other forms of
seafood it's in the salt taken from the
ocean water it's in things that don't
even come from the ocean like fruits and
vegetables with apples having the
highest concentration of microplastics
and broccoli and carrots trailing behind
and sometimes is even found in the air
we breathe
decades of plastic use have contaminated
our air water and soil eating just a
bite of an apple can now mean eating
hundreds of thousands of bits of plastic
at the same time and just like when
cigarettes first came out there wasn't
decades of smoking history to base
studies off of so doctors just assumed
it wasn't bad for you giving smoking the
stamp of approval today we still don't
have a clear picture on what the
long-term effects of consuming plastic
are yes we love plastics so much that we
become one with the same material
concocted by plastic and oil giants
now if you watch this channel you know
that i am not the biggest fan of taxes
or a giant all-consuming government
that's why i'm not gonna use this
opportunity to push you guys to support
more government programs funded by taxes
more regulations like every
environmentalist instead i'm gonna push
you guys to donate to team seas a
campaign where all the biggest craters
are coming together to raise 30 million
dollars to get 30 million pounds of
trash out of the ocean it's led by mr
beast an incredibly kind and smart guy
and mark rober last year their goal was
20 million dollars to plant 20 million
trees a feat they thought wasn't
possible at first but that they ended up
shattering with 23 million dollars in
donations and 2 600 trees being planted
every day to this day and this year
they're stepping up a notch instead of
20 million dollars is 30 million and
instead of one dollar for planting a
tree it's one dollar for every pound of
trash removed from the ocean to put this
into context 30 million pounds of trash
is the equivalent of 85 football fields
at one foot thick of trash or like we
mentioned earlier it's the equivalent of
removing somewhere around three years
worth of plastic from the ocean and to
do this team trees has partnered with
the ocean conservancy and the ocean
cleanup who are professionals at this to
remove 30 million pounds of trash every
day over the next three years but it's
only going to be possible with your help
whoever said money can't buy happiness
hasn't given enough away and like i
mentioned earlier it doesn't matter
where you land on the political spectrum
i think we can all agree that less trash
in the ocean done on a voluntary manner
not through coercion is probably a good
thing
even if you don't care about the
environment like i've never been a
hardcore environmentalist you should
still donate for your own selfish
benefits not only does it make you
happier by giving away money but
donating just five dollars equals five
pounds less of trash that could end up
in the air you breathe in the food you
eat not just for you but for your family
and loved ones that's why i will be
donating a thousand dollars of my own
money to get a literal ton of trash out
of the ocean but for you it can be as
little as five dollars whatever you can
afford and you can join me by clicking
the donate button below or by going to
teamses.org with the link below click
the donate button or head to
teamsees.org to show the world just what
our community can do
[Music]
guys the link to donate to team seats
will be linked below right next to that
subscribe button and speaking of
subscribing we make video essays
documentaries just like this one every
single week on the most provocative
stuff in the world of money power war
and crime and it's free too all you have
to do is click subscribe if you want
more daily life kind of stuff you can
follow me on instagram jaketrain.io but
that's going to wrap it up thank you for
being part of the watchdog n club keep
sharpening that mind stay dangerous out
there and i will see you guys in the
next one
[Music]
you